the island of Taiwan wants to show that
it's ready
by military plane we were taken to see
preparations that suddenly feel a whole
lot more serious
Taiwan is self-governing but China sees
this land as its own
so an invasion scenario is being
rehearsed the enemy in red helmets
Landing dispersing
infantry responding
both conscription and defense spent have
recently increased here a sense of
urgency renewed
and that's in part because this is not
all rehearsal
[Music]
these jets are the ones that routinely
scramble when Chinese fighter planes get
threateningly close
it's an increasingly precarious now
daily occurrence one misstep could
easily spiral there is clearly a
recognition here that the threats from
China are intensifying and hurricanes
are becoming more frequent and the
messaging feels more serious questions
over whether Taiwan is prepared for what
might come have never felt more present
Pilots like Lieutenant Colonel Wu bong
young already shoulder a lot and know
things could easily get worse is this
military ready to deal with that threat
we are pirates we are fight Pilots we
are prepared for for every to to face
every kind of challenge taiwan's foreign
minister is acutely aware of the risks
it might take only one or two minutes
for them to come to our airspace so it's
very threatening fortunately our Pilots
are very well trained they know that
they cannot fire the first shot to start
the war he told us exclusively how
they've ratcheted up the situation is
getting worse and we need to prepare for
the worst possible scenario and does
that worst possible scenario now feel
more likely yes indeed if you look at
the trajectory of the Chinese military
trade against Taiwan it is more likely
and unusually he shared insights on when
it could happen uh to me uh 2027 is a
year that we need to watch out Xi
Jinping is likely to go into his fourth
term if you look at the Chinese
situation right now the economy is going
down people are not happy if Xi Jinping
cannot change the situation domestically
in China he might want to resort to a
use of force or creating crisis
externally to divert domestic attention
or to show to the Chinese that he has
accomplished something
a wall would come with seriously high
stakes it could well pit the U.S against
China but there is a grit a resolve here
from a people who know they need to be
ready Helena Smith Sky News in Taipei